[Music]
i love your accent i have to say i'm a
connoisseur of accidents australian
accent i think you're a connoisseur i i
love there are certain accents i really
like french accent can be a very
beautiful accent to do what to listen to
uh to listen i can't do it
i'm a silly cartoon fool okay but uh but
australian uh it's a it's a it's a i
think it's a sexy accent i really like
oh that's really sweet do you watch
flight of the concords uh well that's
yes i love those guys i love flight of
the concourse but i don't watch it for
their sexy accent sarah winter does an
awesome accent in that and she's called
keith yeah i don't my accent's all over
the place when i go back to australia if
i talk to australians it gets much
thicker but i don't know you sort of
spend 18 hours a day speaking in an
american accent that it becomes this
kind of
atlantic thing yeah right right but then
you go back and within a few hours
you're right back in it you're right it
only changes because you want to be
understood really i think well i'm
curious in australia okay it's the
holiday season i have no idea what they
do in australia about christmas how
different we don't have christmas
industry yes you must have christmas in
australia but but how you can't fool me
i know there's christmas but i know that
when you get to other countries they do
weird things on christmas that always
seems strange to me they're only weird
because you don't do them no i don't
know why no america's right yeah that's
bad
and other countries are weird well i
like you'll be in you'll be in belgium
and they'll say for christmas we put out
half an apple for santa and then he
leaves us a peanut and you're like
great belgium yeah in australia we just
put out beer like that yeah that's what
it takes for santa and then yeah my poor
mom kept you know like please not the
carrots for the the reindeer oh you
would leave carrots for the ring no we
like cocoa or cookies and milk you leave
carrots for the reindeer well we used to
sometimes in beer yeah for santa claus
but santa claus you know who's in board
shorts and rides you know white
kangaroos
does he really have
he wears he wears wrap around shades and
he's like good extremely cool yeah with
like a stubby cooler that you know with
the jingle bells that's
and what about like traditions like i
mean obviously it's it's hot in
australia you don't have like stockings
by a fireplace do you no but i don't
know if that's just i mean my mum's like
i don't know if that was because we just
didn't have stockings but we'd always
put pillowcases up at the end of our
beds like and santa would which is
creepy when you think about it santa
would then crawl into our bedrooms and
then
put the presents under our bed while we
were sleeping god bless my mother yeah
but my mother that's so weird like he's
i mean it's not that creepy it's santa
so he's allowed to come in and put
himself at this point that's right
he gave him a few beers you're like come
on under the bed
i always go back to that one quote i
apologize okay my mom um sorry i think
this is so sweet mum will love it my
mother was a single mom and so um we
would leave a note for santa with the
beer and then mum would often write i
didn't know it was mum at the time santa
would write hey who's the hot chick you
know him oh your mom would do that
[Applause]
i think of the poor darling like you
know assembling trampolines good for
your mom by yourself and getting the
giggles right you're like that horny
santa
[Laughter]
i want to ask you a question you have
lived at different times in australia
the united states
and canada
and you are single
tell us is there could you see a
difference when you're dating in the
approach of men
in in in these different countries
american men versus australian versus
canadian canadians australian men i mean
it's a cliche because it's australian
managers blunt and i think that there's
just not um
i don't know you meet them for a beer if
you like each other then it's on and
that's kind of how it works there's no
there's no dancing around there's no
dancing and then uh
yeah i think i don't know i think
americans tend to they're very upfront
they're like hey i'd love to take you
for a dinner would you but you don't
know how many people they're taking you
know to dinner you don't know if it's a
day
and then i don't know i find canadians
you have to just
they're shy you have to rock up hi i'm
i'm i'm i'm anna can i give you my
number which i i've done you do that
i've done that a couple of times
my face would fall off if you did that
to me
seriously if i you know
i love my wife or maybe that's why
i'm saying if you
walked up and were like hey i'm in i
want your number i would i would just i
would turn into a mist i would turn into
a
an orange mist and just disappear
that would freak me out no i'm not that
scary
you don't know me